[Music]
[Applause]
steph curry breaks the three-point
record at madison square garden last
night there were a lot of celebrities
there
pete davidson was there spike lee was
there you know this felt like it was a
an ideal situation reggie miller was on
the call ray allen was there ray allen
who was in the spike lee movie he got
game
and it's at madison square garden all of
the great memories there with all of the
great players everybody's had a moment
it feels like at madison square garden
and you start to look around you go okay
there's a lot of celebrities there and
then paulie goes
marv albert's there i said i said marv's
not calling the game paulie goes no marv
is there watching the game
the great marv albert joining us on the
program so you went as a fan marv
yes i did that thank you i i my wife and
i
uh
wanted to see
uh we have eight plants to come watch
golden state uh we missed them in
brooklyn a couple weeks back
so
uh what what a joyous moment that it was
last night and to see the garden crowd
respond i i knew they would i knew
they'd be rooting for steph
uh
but uh
it was it was just terrific particularly
with ray allen reggie miller there it
was a perfect setting
is there somebody who is comparable if
we say greatest shooter of all time
is steph curry in your opinion the
greatest shooter you've ever seen
i i would say
uh yes uh and he did it in a different
way i mean reggie is right with him uh i
think ray allen
is certainly there things were different
people were not shooting as many
three-pointers at that time even in
reggie's day
uh coach the co as reggie had mentioned
to me i mean the coach would be
upset if you take too many steve kerr
wants steph even if he's missing as he
has recently
uh
he's been
in an unusual slump as of late
uh for steph that is
but he says keep taking him i i know
that when james harden
was uh on fire with
mike d'antoni said keep taking threes i
mean mike had already said hey we're
going to take 45 50
threes a game
as a team which sounded astounding but
they did and uh
it's not always a successful way to win
i think the way the warriors play
and with uh
the type of players they have the way
they swing the ball so successfully
uh it it is the way to go and when klay
thompson comes back
they are going to be so tough when you
think even though
uh jordan poole has played very well but
with clay and steph and draymond
they are going to be
incredible to watch what do you think
the game is like though in ten years
when it comes to three-point attempts
i hope it doesn't get out of hand i i i
think you know
i think there'll be a lot of uh many
better three-point shooters because i
think kids now
are taking the deep shots
influenced by what they're seeing but if
it's circus atmosphere uh i i think it
would be out of hand you you don't want
to see only threes being fired up i i
would like to see more of a post game i
i think
uh
uh passing centers and
centers who can shoot threes effectively
but not take too many uh are you know
would be interesting to watch
but uh i i hope it's not uh you know
uh i know the aba when they uh started
out with the three which turns out
you know influenced the nba when it was
the merger i i thought at times they
would just be firing them up and it
wasn't taken seriously
but with
with steph any night he can just
catch fire and i think if reggie played
today or ray allen
they would be
very similar to steph
but steph is special because i mean he
he can shoot from the logo and
perhaps only trae young
out of uh nba players today
would be successful doing it the same
way i think trey eventually will uh have
a steph curry effect
but also if you look back though marv in
the history of the game the player who
would have benefited the most by having
the green light to shoot as many threes
as he wanted would be who
well the guys that come to mind who were
hitting basically three point up they
counted for two
uh were a couple of guys who played for
the knicks well jerry lucas has won who
also played for you know cincinnati but
uh
dave the butcher would have been an
incredible three-point shooter i don't
think he would have shot us you know a
large amount of three-pointers but he
would have really been
uh
just a great uh three-point shooter
those are the those are the two guys who
i recall
who uh
what about birds
larry bird
birdwood would have shot more yeah he
would have been tremendous but he was so
good going to the basket
you know when a big man
does it i think steph had to create and
get better and better at what he does
because the lack of size uh although
he
trained so hard during this offseason
and is in such
excellent shape
uh that he actually does a you know good
job defensively decently
so i mean his whole game has has to me
what's
so wonderful about the way he plays is
the joy and the joy of the garden
but not for the knicks at the start of
the game
was just unbelievable to watch it it
really was like everybody was happy for
it for him but it was so it was so nice
we're talking to marv albert
so it had to be a little strange that
you had this game this moment this
atmosphere and you're not calling
that moment
it was probably the first
well i've gone to games
before when i was
when i actually was broadcasting you
know just to see a team you know
you you would might go to if they played
the night before
um
it wasn't that strange
it really it really wasn't that strange
to me i was so how so uh so much fun
to be there to watch the game uh
it really it really was not okay how
about i give you a chance to call it
it would have been a great game to call
no no just a moment marv if i just say
you know wiggins to curry
oh it would have been no no you're
supposed to make the call i'd like i i
i'm letting you you're leading you're
leading me i see yes i'm giving you the
assist i'm john stockton here okay let's
do it again okay all right
well
i shouldn't be saying wiggins to curry
unless you want to be the color
commentary but you know that wouldn't
work
okay all right i'll be the i'll be the
color commentary and then you
so
it'll be wiggins to steph curry so i'll
i'll let you make the call okay
hey ready all right okay are you gonna
make you're gonna make the crowd sound
oh god
[Applause]
steps back
yes
excellent crowd noise
and you weren't really into it you would
have given me a more definitive yes
it's too early
don't want to wake up the neighborhood
yes i scare my my pugs are sleeping oh
okay we don't want to mess that up were
you on the call when marovich had 68
against the knicks
no i was i was not okay uh
uh the biggest
let's see at the garden i was on the
michael jordan uh call when he had the
55 that was pretty incredible
uh and
bernard king had huge games at the
garden i was trying to think back
uh stupid of course reggie had the uh
uh eight points in in nine seconds you
know so but if you were going to like
reggie's eight in nine seconds
how do you explain it so quick you know
it was also uh uh
i didn't do that game i was on another
playoff game as it turns out but uh that
was phenomenal
in that uh
you know there was so quick it's not
like you know a setup and a score that
was
that was amazing you know we always tell
them stuff you know on one of them but
he laughs anyway but it was so great
seeing you know
reggie and i did the game in boston when
ray allen broke his record
and uh if i i always i kidded him last
night because in that game
uh rey's mom came over to our broadcast
table and just hugged reggie you know
this is during the broadcast
and i said both
uh
ray his mom
uh and steph's
parents will come over and hug reggie
but it didn't happen
well i was looking for a hug of thought
yeah uh well it's great to talk to you
marv and uh thanks for joining us as
always i'll let you go back to sleep
okay
thanks dad happy holidays thank you
buddy thank you my best to your wife
that's marv albert the voice
the nba